hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück auf
einem kanal heute mal aus der küche weil
es draußen heute unglaublich laut ist in
diesem video zeige ich euch welche
gemüse ihr immer vorziehen direkt ins
beet und raus pflanzen könnt das ist
nämlich eine ganze menge weil im mai die
letzten spätfröste ton ab mitte mai
können auch alle wärmeliebenden gemüse
nach draußen umziehen und deswegen ist
es ein ganz wichtiger und super schöner
monat im gartenjahr
also lasst uns loslegen mit den gemüsen
die man jetzt zu hause vor ziehen kann
bei mir hat das vorziehen das ganze
garten ja über eigentlich nie auf weil
ich immer wieder neue gemüse aussehe
ich sehe meine gemüse auch gerne
gestaffelt aus also in unterschiedlichen
setzen damit nicht alle auf einmal reis
werden sondern man kontinuierlich ernten
kann
und jetzt kommt die liste mit den
gemüsen die ihr jetzt zu hause im haus
oder auch im gewächshaus vorziehen
könnte und der ist allererste gemüse ist
der brokkoli ein gemüse das nicht ganz
so anfänger freundlich ist also wenn du
dein erstes garten ja ist dann lass den
erstmal weg aber für alle
fortgeschritteneren gärtner und
gärtnerinnen eine super sache ich liebe
die sorte rameau so calabrese kann ich
euch gerne auch hier unten einblenden
brokkoli ist also ein kandidat der jetzt
wunderbar im haus vorgezogen werden kann
der zweite kandidat der gemüse die jetzt
im haus vorgezogen werden können wäre
der grünkohl
da kann ich euch sehr die sorte
westländer winter empfehlen was jetzt
auch noch geht sind gurken
da sind meine allerliebsten sorten zwei
salatsorten die eine heißt tanja die
andere heißt market more ich glaube es
ist 76 martin [ __ ] und irgendeine zahl
wenn ich euch auch gerne hier unten ein
und wenn ihr saure gurken einlegen
wollte oder einkochen wollt dann
empfehle ich euch sehr die sorte vor
gebirgs trauben eine ganz tolle einlege
sollte da muss man eben unterschiedliche
gurken anbau
je nachdem ob man die frisch essen will
oder ob man die für den winter haltbar
machen wir in form von sauren gurken
dann auch ein super tolles gemüse gerade
weil es auch so schnell wächst bis der
kohlrabi da sind meine sorten tipps
langlo super schmelz und wie heißt ja
nochmal zu es da genau ein lilafarbener
sehr schöner kohlrabi alles drei super
sorten super schmerz macht sehr schöne
große und sehr zarte knollen als wurst
da ist dann so der hübsche und da ist
auch noch absolut super sorte den super
ertrag abwirft ja wenn du nicht schon
kürbis vorgezogen hast dann hast du
jetzt auch noch zeit das nachzuholen ich
mache das er immer mitte april
ich sähe am liebsten hokkaido kürbisse
aus aber auch gerne muskatkürbis
butternut jetzt haben wir auch noch eine
amerikanische sorte die ich neu
ausprobieren will die heißt home sweet
und eines dieser wintergemüse das jetzt
gesät werden sollte ist auch der auch da
empfehle ich euch die sorte blaugrüner
winter eine ganz tolle sorte die sich
bei uns seit vielen jahren im garten
bewährt hat die frost hat ist und die
man dann den winter über immer nach und
nach ernten kann wenn man eben mal
hunger auf hilft da genau hat dabei
wintergemüse das jetzt gesät werden kann
ist der rosenkohl
da empfehle ich euch die sorte ide mader
wird bei uns super erträge ab also da
hat man wirklich richtig lange stangen
die voll mit röschen besetzt sind eine
richtig tolle sorte da wäre es jetzt
auch zeit für die ersten ausfahrten dann
ein gemüse dass man auch wunderbaren
freiland sehen kann dass sich aber gerne
vorziehe weil es ein licht kaymer ist
und der boden draußen sehr schnell
austrocknet gerade wenn es so wenig
geregnet wie im moment ist salat salat
kann man wunderbar auch im haus
vorziehen da empfehle ich euch für die
kalten monate ja immer die sorte papier
aber jetzt wird es langsam zeit an einen
salat zu denken der im sommer geerntet
werden kann und im sommer hat man oft
das problem dass der salat sehr schnell
schießt das heißt blüten bildet deswegen
würde ich jetzt eine chance feste sorte
empfehlen und dabei ich am allerliebsten
diese orte piraten dann geht es weiter
mit dem weißkohl da sehe ich früh im
jahr immer schnell wachsende sorten
damit man die früh im jahr auch ernten
kann
aber jetzt ist es an der zeit für die
langsamer wachsende sorten die man dann
auch zu sauerkraut weiter
arbeiten kann wie man erst im herbst
ernten kann und da ist meine
allerliebste sorte dormann die schnell
wachsenden sorgen kann man jetzt auch
noch anbauen da ist meine liebste sorte
nagels früh weiß für zucchini ist es
jetzt auch noch nicht zu spät also wenn
du noch keine zucchini gesellt hat dann
macht das gerne kann man auch wunderbar
im haus vorziehen bei einem kürbis
gewächsen also bei gurken melonen bei
zucchini und kürbis na klar ist auch ein
kürbis gewächs also alle kürbisgewächse
immer direkt in einen großen topf sehen
das ist ein ganz häufiger fehler den ich
immer wieder sehe es gibt noch viele
andere fehler die man bei der anzucht
machen kann habe ich auch mal ein video
drüber gemacht das könnt ihr euch gerne
bei anschauen das habe ich euch da oben
in der ecke verlinkt und jetzt noch gar
nicht beraten welche ist meine liebste
zuglinie sollte ist das ist die zug-
oder eine ganz klassische zucchini die
wahrscheinlich auch viele von euch
anbauen und der letzte kandidat zum
vorziehen ist der zucker mais da könnt
ihr jetzt im haus zuckermais pflänzchen
vorziehen müsst ihr aber nicht die könnt
ihr auch direkt ins freiland säen und
wenn wir schon dabei sind machen wir
weiter mit den gemüsen die man direkt
ins freiland sehen kann
da unterscheide ich immer zwischen den
sorten die erst nach den spätfrösten
gesät werden können und denen die man
jetzt schon anfang mai sehen kann
aber ihr könnt ihr auch immer auf das
wetter achten bei uns sind zum beispiel
bisher noch gar keine frosta angekündigt
im ganzen mai das heißt wer mutig ist
könnte man es auch jetzt schon wagen die
empfindlicheren gemüse aus zu sehen
aber es ist schon sicherer einfach bis
mitte mai zu warten mit den
empfindlicher und genießen das sage ich
jetzt immer dazu ob das frostempfindlich
ist oder nicht und boden sind
frostempfindlich vor stunden sind ein
ganz tolles gemüse weil die super viel
ertrag abwerfen da kann man sich im
sommer dann kaum retten vor bohnen und
eine ganz tolle sorte die ich euch
empfehlen kann ist die sorte köppel tipi
die macht superschöne lilafarbene boden
und die bei euch super gerne an dann
auch eine super spannende kultur die man
jetzt draußen ins beet sehen kann der
chicorée chicorée erntet man eigentlich
erst im winter so wie viele andere
gemüse die hier
ja auch aber da ist das spannende dass
man im herbst eben die wurzeln ausgräbt
und den dann im keller treibt da kann
ich gerne weil ein video darüber machen
das ist super schön wenn man dann im
winter immer noch so ein kleines beet im
keller hat wo man sich seine curis
ernten kann
und das funktioniert wirklich
einwandfrei also wir haben so schöne
theorie es gab jetzt diesen winter da
kann ich gerne nächsten winter wenn es
soweit ist mal ein video drüber machen
wenn ihr mitmachen wollt wenn ihr auch
theorie im keller treiben wollte ihr
braucht dafür auch gar nicht so einen
kühlen keller also wir haben zum
beispiel das problem ist unser keller
sehr sehr warm ist aber es hat trotzdem
gut geklappt also ich werde euch alle
ermutigen wenn ihr lust darauf habt
jetzt auch chicorée auszusehen dann kann
ich euch im herz zeigen wie ihr das dann
macht mit den wurzeln und der ganzen
treibe rein ich habe bisher nur eine
theorie sorte ausprobiert aber die hat
sich bei uns absolut bewährte schmeckt
auch sehr lecker und auch sehr mild das
ist die sorte makoun erbsen und
zuckererbsen kann man jetzt auch
wunderbar rinspeed seelen das kann man
ja schon seit februar das mache ich auch
immer wieder einsetzen wenn die erste
charge hand hoch ist wird die zweite
gesät in die zweite charge handtuch ist
sehe ich die dritte und so haben wir
dann auch kontinuierlich das ganze jahr
über unterschiedliche erbsen die reif
werden die zucker ärzte die ich am
liebsten anbau ist die sorte ambrosia
und die mag erbse die ich super art
liebe das heißt mag erbsen sind so
erbsen die man zum kochen ernte wo man
dann nicht die schote ist sondern die
kleinen erbsen innen drin
die heißt ambassador wenn ich mich nicht
ganz andere aber ich bleibe es euch ja
hier unten ein jetzt kommt ein kandidat
den wie eben auch schon mal hatten guten
kannst du nämlich ab mitte mai auf
wunderbar rinspeed zellen die wachsen
super gut auch wenn man die einfach
direkt seht ich staffel meine gurken
sogar sehr gerne das heißt ich ziehe ein
paar im haus vor und ich sehe ein paar
direkt im garten aus weil irgendwann
alle gurkenpflanzen von mehltau befallen
das passiert in jedem jahr egal was man
macht da kann man nicht viel gegen tun
außer dass man dann eben noch jüngere
pflanzen in petto hat die noch robuster
sind und davon nicht so stark befallen
werden und dann weiter produzieren das
heißt ich teile meine burgen die ich
anbauen möchte ein in die dich vorziehe
und die die ich direkt sehe damit man
dann eben später im jahr noch diese
robusten jüngeren pflanzen hat die
sorten habe ich euch ja schon empfohlen
das sind die gleichen wie eben auch
genau so funktioniert das mit kürbis den
könnt ihr auch ab mitte mai direkt ins
pc dann könnt ihr direkt im speziellen
den mangold da sehe ich am allerliebsten
eine wunderschöne sorte die ganz bunt
daher kommt die hat gelbe orange farbene
rote und pinkel stengel auf weiße sind
glaube ich dabei dass sie so so schön
aus und das ist die sorte rainbow also
einfach ein sorten mix der sich super
schön macht ich finde das immer toll
wenn gemüse nicht nur lecker sind
sondern auch optisch etwas hermachen im
beet und das kann rainbow auf jeden fall
hören könnt ihr natürlich auch sehen
da sehe ich jetzt hin zu der jahreszeit
immer am liebsten die sorte milan
das ist eine tolle leckere super
ertragreiche unkomplizierte möhren sorte
für pastinaken ist es fast schon ein
bisschen spät aber wenn ihr noch keine
pastinaken gewählt habt dann macht das
gerne jetzt eine tolle sorte wer zb die
halb lange weiße pastinaken sind für
dich supertolle gewächse nicht nur weil
sie wunderschön aus dem beet die werden
ja richtig kräftig und groß und üppig
sondern auch weil es einfach toll ist
mit pastinaken zu kochen die sind so süß
und so aromatisch kann ich mir gar nicht
mehr wegdenken ja ein gemüse das quasi
immer geht sind radieschen die sind auch
super schnell erntereif meine liebste
radieschen sorte ist die tore dann
kannst du jetzt auch rote beete sehen
wenn du dir gerne isst macht das auf
jeden fall eine tolle süße leckere sorte
ist die sorte robusta beziehungsweise
rote kugel zwei die wird unter
unterschiedlichen namen verkauft die
sorte ist aber die gleiche sorte und
hummer superlecker supergut der nächste
kandidat ist der rucola den kann man
wunderbar
jetzt aussehen ich weiß gar nicht ob es
da bestimmte sorten wird die den rucola
den wie anbau und er hat glaube ich gar
keine sorten bezeichnung da ist
wunderbar dass er sich auch immer selber
aussehen das heißt ich sehe jetzt gar
keinen rucola mehr sondern ich lasse
ihnen immer jedes jahr blühen und so
sieht er sich dann selber aus und ist
quasi eine chance dadurch dass er sich
einfach immer selber weiter vermehrt
haben wir einfach eine ecke in unserem
garten wo immer hohler wächst ihm kann
man auch quasi das ganze jahr über
geerntet selbst im winter ist echt eine
super tolle sache ja ich hab eben schon
erwähnt salat kann man auch ins freiland
säen muss man nicht im haus vorziehen
dann ist es aber ganz wichtig dass man
wirklich darauf achtet die erde feucht
zu halten weil man salat war mir nur
oben auf die erde drauf streusel und da
kann es eben gerade bei heißen sonnigen
wetter super schnell passieren dass die
erde aus trocken wird das heißt da am
besten zweimal am tag nachschauen und
gießen damit die pflänzchen auch
überhaupt aufgehen und anwachsen können
dann kannst du auch spinat sehen da sehe
ich jetzt gemein die sorte karason es
ist wie beim salat auch weil der spinat
im sommer sehr schnell in die blüte geht
da gibt es ja auch die sogenannte spinat
ricke eine zeit im sommer wo die spinat
klassen alle blühen wollen und man gar
kein spieler hat ernten kann und eine
sorte die eben nicht so leicht blüht ist
die sorte amazon kann ich euch sehr
empfehlen wenn ihr so spät im jahr noch
spinat sehen wollt stangenbohnen gehen
jetzt auch die gehören wiederum zu den
pflanzen die keinen frost vertragen
können also stangenbohnen immer nur nach
den eisheiligen sehr nach mitte mai wenn
garantiert keine spätfröste mehr drohen
da bei euch sehr gerne eine sorte an die
heißt blau hilde man kann käfer boden
anbauen die sind auch wunderschön
also da gibt es ganz ganz ganz viele
tolle boden
ich glaube der reiki hat doch auch mal
diese meter boden angebaut die finde ich
auch super spannend und sich auch mal
ausprobieren
die werden dann ewig lagen also da gibt
es super viele super schöner wohnen auch
in ganz unterschiedlichen farben sucht
euch einfach eine sorte aus ich finde
käfer bohnen super
gerade wenn man als die als trockenboden
anbauen will die blauhelme baue ich eher
an wenn ich eher die boden dann frisch
ernten möchte zurück in ihr könnt ihr ab
direkt ins beet zählen mache ich das
genauso wie bei den gurken dass sich da
eine pflanze vorziehe und ein oder zwei
pflanzen direkt ins pc
damit heben der mehltau nicht alle
pflanzen auf einmal befällt und dann die
ernte irgendwann im jahr wegbricht so
kann man dann später im jahr immer noch
mehr früchte ernten zuckermais kann man
jetzt auch direkt sehen ich glaube da
habe ich eben sogar den sorten tipp
vergessen am liebsten bauen wir die
sorte traum und an eine ganz süße
leckere ertragreiche tolle zukommen
sollte und zu guter letzt kannst du
jetzt zwiebeln seelen eine tolle sorte
einer lager zwiebel ist die sorgt die
riems bürger bingo ich glaub ich hoffe
ich ab jetzt richtig ausgesprochen
das ist eine seite sie sich sehr gut
lagern lässt ansonsten kannst du auch
andere zu bauen wenn du zb
frühlingszwiebeln sehen willst kannst du
das jetzt auch wunderbar machen es jetzt
eine gute zeit für aber vielleicht
willst du ja auch pflanzen kaufen gehen
im baumarkt oder bei einer gärtnerei
oder überlegt welche deiner vorgezogene
pflanzen du jetzt pflanzen kannst
deswegen kommen wir jetzt zur dritten
kategorie nämlich den pflanzen die man
jetzt vorgezogen ins beet pflanzen kann
das ist einmal wieder die gurke alle
gurkenpflanzen die ihr vorgezogen habt
könnt ihr ab mitte mai ins freiland
setzen dass es wieder so ein gemüse das
sehr frostempfindlich ist das gehört
also in die kategorie die erst ab mitte
mai gepflanzt werden können
das zweite gemüse wer knollensellerie
wenn ihr da welche vorgezogen habt oder
auch benzin gekauft habt dann könnt ihr
die auch schon anfang mai pflanzen der
es nicht ganz so frostempfindlich ihr
könnt ihr aber auch als mitte meine
pflanzen das macht eigentlich keinen
unterschied knollensellerie ist wirklich
ein zu meiner liebsten gartengemüse weil
der so rundlich ist so viel charakter
hat kann es gar nicht so richtig
beschreiben es ist auch ein sehr
gemütliches gemüse weil der sich
wirklich zeit lässt bis dann eine ernte
bei rumkommt dass es ja ich weiß nicht
warum aber ich liebe knollensellerie und
meine allerliebste sorte ist die sorte
monarch kohlrabi kann man jetzt auch
auslands
dann müsst ihr auch nicht zimperlich mit
sein der kann frost ablehnen könnt ihr
gerne jetzt schon in speed pflanzen auch
anfang mai es gab ein problem wer aber
etwas frostempfindlich ist es der kürbis
der kann erst ab mitte mai im speed der
ist sehr frostempfindlich also da
wirklich erst bis nach den letzten
frösten warten paprika ist auch so eine
frostbeule die auch erst nach mitte mai
nach den eisheiligen raus pflanzen
da gibt es ja ganz tolles orten ich bei
paprika auch sehr gut und sehr
erfolgreich im freiland an am besten an
einem etwas geschützten ort da kommen
die noch besser klar ich baue die vor
einer sandsteinmauer an und da baue ich
am allerliebsten die sorten neue siedler
ideal und rote augsburger an gerade rote
augsburger ist eine richtig tolle so
hatte die machen nicht die früchte die
man aus dem supermarkt gewohnt ist
sondern eher kleinere spitz geformte ein
bisschen bilden wendigeren früchte die
aber umso aromatischer sind also kann
ich euch wirklich nur empfehlen probiert
das mal aus viele leute denken wir über
das man paprika know in italien anbauen
kann stimmt überhaupt nicht
genauso auberginen die wachsen bei uns
auch wunderbar wir wohnen jetzt nicht
unbedingt im weinbaugebiet wir wohnen in
nordhessen und da habe ich am
allerliebsten die sorte blaue königin an
wenn ihr schon rosenkohl vorgezogen
haben oder plätzchen gekauft habt könnt
ihr jetzt auch aus pflanzen genauso wie
salat den kann man wunderbar ab februar
aus pflanzen je nach sorte in den kalten
nächten kann man die ja immer noch mit
einem vlies schützen aber das ist mal im
eigentlich nicht mehr nötig selbst wenn
es nochmal friert die können wirklich
mehr ab als man denen so zutraut ja dann
ein ganz tolles gemüse dass man jetzt
pflanzen kann sind die tomaten
darüber habe ich letzte woche ein video
gemacht könnt ihr euch gerne da oben
anschauen
das ist übrigens super toll wie gut dass
angekommen ist hat mich richtig gefreut
auf eure ganzen kommentare zu lesen
und ja tomaten sind eines der besten
gemüse im garten oder da sind wir uns
wahrscheinlich alle einig zu den
tomatensorten könnte man auch echt
stundenlang reden weil da gibt es so
viele unterschiedliche auch für ganz
unterschiedliche bedürfnisse
da habe ich auch schon ein video drüber
gemacht das kann ich euch auch gern da
oben verlinkten wenn ihr euch
inspirieren lassen wollt welche
tomatensorten
unsere lieblingssorten sind und warum
also tomaten erst nach den eisheiligen
raus pflanzen weil die auch sehr
frostempfindlich sind die sind sogar bei
temperaturen unter zehn grad relativ
unzufrieden und reagieren mit wachstums
stockungen das sind schon kleine mimosen
was das angeht ja weiß wohl kann man
jetzt ab wunderbar aus pflanzen habe ich
auch gerade vor ein paar tagen gemacht
egal ob ihr pflanzen vorgezogen habt
oder die kauft wieso hatten habe ich
euch ja auch schon erwähnt also eine
super sache bei school anzubauen ist
auch unkomplizierter als zum beispiel
rotkohl brokkoli oder blumenkohl
die gehören ja eher so zu den türken im
gemüsegarten weiß cool ist etwas
einfacher anzubauen wenn du dich mehr an
die kopfkohl pflanzen rennwagen möchtest
dann fang am besten damit an verzeiht
fehler er als zum beispiel der rotkohl
rotkohl ist auch ein gemüse dass du
jetzt raus pflanzen kannst da bei euch
am allerliebsten die sorte granat an
aber wie gesagt rotkohl ist echt eher
was für erfahrenere gerd nach irgend
weil es da schon schwer ist einen
ordentlichen kopf zustande zu bringen
gerade wenn man biologisch gärtnern aber
alle die schon ein bisschen garten
erfahrungen gemacht haben wagt euch da
wo ich mal ran nicht wieder mal
niemanden abschrecken wenn ich immer so
wie wir den rotkohl herziehen
es ist ja auch ein super leckeres tolles
gemüse also kanada den rotkohl die sorte
granat ist wirklich lecker wunderschön
und ja vor gibt bei uns relativ große
köpfe genau so könnt ihr jetzt wirsing
raus pflanzen das ist ja auch ein gemüse
dass man eher im winter erntet die sorte
die ich jetzt pflanze ist die sorte
winter fürst für die ernte dann im
winter also denkt dann euer
wintergemüses wird jetzt echt langsam
zeit sich darüber gedanken zu machen
denn das ist super schöne man nicht nur
im herbst ein bisschen in die optionalen
erntet und dann spät räumt sondern im
winter immer noch super viel aus dem
garten ernten kann und da gibt es so
viele gemüse die man immer noch anbauen
kann ich finde das immer so traurig wenn
ich gern sie die im winter komplett
brach liegen weil das ist auch viel
entspannter im winter zu gärtnern du
hast kaum unkraut du hast kaum
schädlinge und krankheiten und kannst
immer noch so viel selber anbauen also
macht das auf jeden fall es ist jetzt
echt an der zeit daran zu denken auch
wenn der winter noch ganz weit weg
die zucchini kann raus gepflanzt werden
auch erst nach den eisheiligen mitte mai
dann sind die bereit rauszuziehen die
sind genauso wie gurken kürbisse paprika
auberginen et cetera sehr
frostempfindlich also damit jetzt noch
ein bisschen warten aber dann kann es
losgeht das gleiche gilt für zucker mais
die vorgezogenen fans fühlen würde ich
wirklich erst nach den eisheiligen raus
pflanzen auch wenn ihr nicht ganz so
empfindlich auf frost reagieren
es ist doch ein rückschlag für die
pflanze wenn sie dann noch einmal frost
erfährt also es ist schon besser die
noch ein bisschen drin zu behalten und
dann erst raus zu pflanzen wenn wirklich
keine früchte mehr drohen und der letzte
kandidat ist die zwiebel damit meine ich
jetzt sowohl vorgezogene zwiebel fans
gehen die man vielleicht im haus gesät
hat als auch steck zwiebeln die kann man
jetzt auch wunderbar nach draußen ins
bett bringen ich hoffe ihr habt jetzt
inspiration gefunden was er als nächstes
in ihrem garten anbauen könnt wenn ihr
euch jetzt noch fragt welche pflanzen
soll ich dann am besten nebeneinander
pflanzen und wie soll ich das denn alles
so zusammenpuzzeln dass das auch ins
bild passt dann könnt ihr euch gerne
meinen kostenlosen gartenplaner
herunterladen den link packe ich euch
wie immer in die video beschreibung da
habe ich den garten plan erstellt linie
eins zu eins auf euren garten übertragen
könnt wo dann so sachen wie die abfolge
der gemüse schon geregelt ist das heißt
was mache ich denn wenn der salat
abgeerntet das was könnte ich denn
danach sehen da könnt ihr euch entweder
inspirieren lassen oder das einfach eins
zu eins so in ihrem garten umsetzen und
dann das ganze jahr über ganz vielfältig
aus ihrem garten ernten wenn euch das
video gefallen habt dann lasst gerne ein
abo da ich spreche ganz viel über die
selbstversorgung aus dem eigenen garten
immer auch die glocke drücken damit ihr
überhaupt eine benachrichtigung bekommt
von youtube wenn ein neues video
erscheint ich mache immer samstags um 10
neue videos und wenn ihr mal konkrete
garten fragen haben sollt dann schreibt
die gerne in die kommentare aber am
besten immer samstags zwischen 10 und 11
weil da bin ich garantiert online und
beantwortet unter dem neuen video das
der
und immer alle fragen die reinkommen
also zwischen 10 und 11 erreichte mich
da immer auch wenn immer andere fragen
haben die sich jetzt vielleicht nicht um
das video drehen um das video thema
könnt ihr mir da immer fragen stellen
und ich beantworte so viele wie ich kann
und bin da immer jeden samstag online um
da eure fragen zu beantworten da drüben
zeige ich euch wie das mit dem
tomatenpflanzen nochmal genauer
funktioniert und da unten findet ihr
auch ein spannendes video vielleicht
sehen wir uns ja da wieder ansonsten bis
nächste woche
bis dann macht's gut